whether you like it or not we are moving
into a new Cold War and it's between the
United States and China and their
respective allies China is now the
world's second largest economy and
they're the largest military on Earth at
least by like force numbers so what
they're doing is they are challenging
the us-led global order China wants
their own world order one that isn't
based on common values and philosophies
and rules but is based on mutually
beneficial trade relationships power
relationships basically China wants
succession but for geopolitics so what
does this war look like well right now
it's playing out in the form of the U.S
not letting China have its best
technology semiconductors or microchips
they're also fortifying alliances
especially in China's neighborhood to
make sure that China knows that if they
do anything crazy the US and its allies
are right there so this is kind of the
new Cold War we don't really need to
freak out yet because there isn't like
real serious like threat of violence
tomorrow but